[Music]
viewers write to me and they say I'd
like to dress well for work but I can't
afford a good suit I know the good stuff
is expensive sometimes but it's not just
about money it's about dedication let me
introduce you to some of my personal
heroes these guys live in the Republic
of Congo where the average income is
less than $400 per year and yet they
managed to present themselves with style
and pride they suppose that's what they
call themselves
our movement of African dandies that
took off after World War Two in the
Republic of Congo they've become quite
famous now since a large beer company
shot this commercial with them
[Music]
I think we all can take a leaf out of
their book there are a few things you
can do to save money only ever buy in
sales like I do and consider going
secondhand there are amazing bargains
out there go look for second-hand shops
in more expensive areas of big cities
this is where designer suits go to die
go rescue us the Society of elegant
persons of the c'mon
be yourself
you